çok
ama çok önemli
savcım Çok teşekkür ediyorum beni davet
ettiğiniz de içinde çok teşekkür
ediyorum bugün
sınırları aşmak diye bir başlık koyduk
sınırları aşma başlığı En çok da Sarp
sana bakıyorum seninle Zinde senin
yaşlık arkadaşlara çok yakışacak bir
konu
Öncelikle ben bu konuda ne demek
istediğimi bir Kısaca anlatayım Neden
böyle bir başta seviyorum Neden sıklıkla
anlatıyorum
yakın zamanda insanın fabrika ayarları
diye 13 kitaptan oluşan bir seri
yayınladım ve o insanın fabrika ayarları
içerisinde Bizim daha güzel daha mutlu
daha sağlıklı daha üretken bir hayat
yaşayabilmeniz için biyolojik
geçmişimizin bize getirdiği bedensel ve
zihinsel özelliklerimizi iyi tanımamızı
çok önemli olduğunu anlatmaya
çalışıyorum ve İnsan bedeninde kendini
gösteren özelliklerin bizim hayat O çok
fark etmediğimiz bazı sorunlara da
kaynaklık ettiğini anlatmaya çalışıyorum
bunların içerisinde hepimizin bildiği
gibi senin hareketsiz kalmak Bizim bize
hasta ediyor çok yemek bizi hasta ediyor
fazla besin tüketmek yalnız kalmak bize
hiç iyi gelmiyor moralimizi öpücük
durumumuz bozuluyor efendim çok stresli
olmak fonksiyon görmemizi Hatta uzun
dönemde hasta olmamızı ömrünün
kısalmasına sebep oluyor ve 5 inci madde
olarak da insanın kendi sınırlarını
zorlamak zorunda olan tek canlı olduğunu
anlatmaya çalışıyorum Bugün de bu
insanın fabrika ayarlarını V başlığını
Aslında V maddesini burada bir başlık
olarak konuşacağız yalancı kısaca
İnsan neden diğer canlılardan farklı ve
bu farkının bu sınırları aşma meselesine
Ne alakası var bir kısaca onu anlatmaya
çalışıyorum size şimdi eğer diğer
dünyadaki canlılara Bakar Bir de kendi
şu bedenimizi bir çıplak olarak düşünür
ve diğer canlılarla 1K bu tırsak çok
komik ve böyle acil bedenimiz olduğunu
göreceğiz çırılçıplak Dünyada Hiçbir
ortamda annemizden doğduğumuz haliyle
hayatımızı sürdüremiyoruz O yüzden şu
anda hepimizin üstünde kıyafetler var
evler Yapıyoruz bir şeyler yapıyoruz
onların içinde yaşamamız gerekiyor ama
tabiattaki bütün canlılar biliyorsunuz
doğdukları haliyle işte biraz biliyorlar
geliyorlar tüyleri Kürtleri zırhları
Neyse bir şeyler var üstünde yaşayıp
gidiyorlar hiçbir Ben bu sabah ne
giyeceğim diye düşünüyorum bu zürafaya
rastlamıyoruz mesela Ama biz hep böyle
bir durum var biz neden böyle zayıf ve
çıplağı diye baktığımızda insana doğru
gelen süreçte bedenimiz zayıfla açtıkça
atalarımızdan bugüne doğru bedenimiz
çıplaklar arttıracağı kafamızı daha çok
zorlamak zorunda kalmıştı Çünkü hayatta
kalmamız çok zor olduğu için aşırı zeki
bir canlı olmak zorunda kalmışız Bu
zekamızla da çok fazla işte dünyada
bugün görüyorsunuz
bu
sessizlik dekorasyonu mi Evet sesi mi
kısıldı açtım Şimdi tabiatta iç ilgisi
olmayan ortamlar kurduk şehir ver işte
böyle teknolojik donanımlar onların
içinde Yaşayıp gidiyoruz ve bu canlının
Tabii ki bu açıdan baktığınızda
hepimizin etme özelliği var
adeta doğduktan Birkaç ay sonra böyle
girebilir bir bebek olduktan sonra bile
hemen böyle bize bir şekilde içinde
bulduğumuz duruma öyle bir isyan etme
bir onun dışına çıkma farklı bir şeyler
yapma işte yavaş yavaş kendini
göstermeye başlıyor Mesela ben
hatırlıyorum daha gençken çocukken oyun
oynarken işte uzay Feza rollerine
bürünür dük süper kahraman olurduk
şeyler bir şeyler olurdu Başka hiçbir
canlıda böyle bir oyun oynama yöntemi
görmezsiniz tabi kendimizi hayalimizde
bile olmadığımız bir şey gibi hayal
etmeyi çok severiz o rollere Zihni
öldürülmeyi oralarda gezmeyi un
hayallerini kurmayı çok severiz bu hayal
kurma yetisini işte aşırı Zeki o canlı
olarak İnsanı diğer canlılardan ayıran
çok önemli bir unsur bir farkımız daha
var diğer canlılardan ya bizimde o
açıdan yine özel olduğumuzu
söyleyebilirim
Beynimiz çok büyük olduğu için dünyaya
biraz erken geliyoruz Normalden daha
erken doğuyoruz belki belgesellerde
görmüşsünüzdür üste gergedanların
zürafaların atların ineklerin yavruları
doğdukları zaman 15-20 dakika içinde
ayağa kalkıp yürümeye başlıyorlar normal
hayatlarını sürdürmeye birkaç saat
içerisinde
başlayabiliyor var ama insan bebeği 3-4
sene en azından ben de bakımına ihtiyaç
duyuyor aile bakımına ihtiyaç duyuyor
çok zayıf kendi başına beslenen
beslenmesi bile mümkün değil Niye böyle
Kafamız çok büyük olduğu için bizim Bey
yani Beynimiz vücudumuza göre çok büyük
olduğu için
anneler bebekleri erken doğurmak zorunda
kalmışlar tarihsel olarak bölümü seçim
yapılmış bir önünüzde ve biz yaklaşık
iki buçuk sene erken doğuyoruz ve erken
doğduğumuz zaman bu Beynimiz dışarıda
gelişmeye devam ediyor Bir çok canlı
anne karnında olan değişim Biz de
dışarıda devam ediyor Bu bize hem çok
büyük bir zayıflık getiriyor Tabii ki
yani Hiçbir şeye bir düz bebekler ağzına
bile Dur dur bir şey götüremedik ler
için annelerin onları beslenmeleri
gerekiyor genelde ama diğer canlılar
öyle değil Hemen toplamaya başlıyorlar
bu çok büyük bir zayıflık hayatta kalmak
için ciddi bir problem ama neyse ki anne
babalar bir şekilde yardım ediyor
atıyoruz oyunları Fakat bu biz aynı
zamanda çok büyük bir avantaj da
sağlıyor hiçbir canlıda olmayan bir şey
oluyor bize içine doğduğumuz ortam
ailenin kültürü ortamı yediği içtiği
işte ne varsa ailenin yaşam ortamında
Biz onları adeta emerek alıyoruz Ve
bambaşka canlılara dönüşüyoruz herkese
Şu soruyu çok sorarım size Herkes işte
doğduğu büyüdüğü bir düşünsün
doğduğu gün ve saatte aynı gün mesai O
başka bir zamanda değil o evde değil de
yan komşunun evinde bir çocuk olarak da
olsaydı Acaba nasıl bir insan olurdu
herkes Şimdi bunu düşünürse ya aynı kişi
olarak dolacak ama bambaşka bir aile
bambaşka bir kültüre dolacak belki Hem
de bunlar Kapı komşusu insanlar olmasına
rağmen kesinlikle aynı insan
olmayacaksınız Dolayısıyla Bizler adına
ben dediğimiz bir kişi olarak yaşıyoruz
ama o ben dediğimiz kişi genellikle
işte zamanını yerini kültürünü inancını
imkanları hiç seçme şansımız olmadığı
bir yerde oluşturuyor işte rastgele bir
ailede dünyaya geliyoruz ve onlar Neyse
biz de biraz öyle oluyoruz Eğer mesela
ben şimdi
Sarpa desem ki Sarp Bana Kendini bir
tanıt sansemiha en iyi tanıtan 10 tane
cümle nedir sence diye sorsam özel işte
adım Sarp krep diyecektim mi birinci bu
herkes önce bir ismini söylüyor Sonra
işte belki okuduğu okulu doğduğu şehrin
app bu kutbal takımını belki inancını
Belki başka bir şey de size dinlediği
müzikler falan öyle sıralayacak bana
şimdi herkes kafasında Bence böyle bir
10 tane madde düşürürsün kendisine böyle
anlatmak istiyorum bir tanıtmak
istiyorum birisine 10 tane cümle kendini
tanıtmak istersin 10 tane cümle şunu
Kafamızda bir dizelim ve sonra bakalım
Bu cümlelerden hangisinin acaba biz
yaşarken kendimiz seçip karar verdik
hangisini bize başkaları verdi Bir
bakalım da ismini kendisi bulan bayan
var mı anne baba verir isimleri
genellikle böyle devam ediyoruz ya da
işte Aile büyüklerinden bir tanesi
sosyal pisliğini seviyordur kesinlikle
seviyor musun Üstünü güzel değil misin
aldığı için her ay Kızlar havalı yani
başka da şansın yoktu bende Sinan'ı
seviyorum Öyle bir isim vermişler ve bir
şekilde onu alışıyorsun mesela değer bir
futbol takımı tutuyorsanız dikkat edin
Muhtemelen Ailenizde çok yakın birisinin
tuttuğu futbol takımını sizde
tutuyorsunuz dur bu şekilde ondan
esinlen mı
yoksa Hani bir futbol takımı tutmanın
çok kötü akıllı bir tarafı yok yani
hangi özelliklerine bakıp tutacaksın ya
da Efendim birçok insan ailesinin dini
inancına sahip olarak yaşamaya devam
ediyor ailesinin iyi dediği her şeyi
kötü diğer şey kötüdür öyle öğreniyor
Çünkü özetle Aslında adına ben dediğimiz
şeyin Peki orijinal bir tarafı yok yani
bizimle pek bilgisi yok gibi gözüküyor
İşte tam bu noktada ben minik bir
tavsiye veriyorum Diyorum ki bu çok
güzel bir şey çünkü biz boş bir zihinle
hayata başlayamadık sağolsunlar
varolsunlar ailemiz bizi hayatta tuttu
yetiştirdi böyle bir sürü bilgiler bizi
koruyacak bizi toplumda yaşamaya
hazırlayacak bir sürü veri yüklediğimiz
harika Ama belli bir yaşa geldiğimiz
özellikle gençlik yaşlarımız da ergenlik
yaşlarında falan bunlarla bazı sorunlar
yaşamaya başlıyoruz Merkez etrafınızda
gördüğünüz Belki siz de yaşadığınız ya
Pek de sizin dediğiniz gibi değilmiş
demeye başladınız haliyle baktığımızda
başka başka oy vermeye başladık işte bu
sırada size öğretilmiş sizin içinde
yetiştiğimiz
kabullere kültüre ters bir şeyler
düşünmeye Belki farklı bir şeyler
yapmaya başlıyorsunuz 5 o zaman ne
oluyor kim olacaksanız o kişi ortaya
çıkmaya başlıyor yavaş yavaş Siz kendi
şahsınıza özel bir insan olmaya doğru
görüşüyorsunuz çocuk yandı Çok fazla
olmuyor erken yaşlarda ama gençlik
yaşlarında yavaş yavaş başlıyor ve 30'lu
40'lı yaşlarında geldiğinizde artık
nasıl bir insan olacağını üç aşağı beş
yukarı belli olmuş oluyor hayatınız öyle
sürdürüyoruz Şimdi burada dikkat çekmek
istediğim konu şu çoğu insan
ailesinden çevresinden yakın işte
insanlardan aldığı temel deneyimlerle
bilgilerle bütün hayatını sürdürebiliyor
ama bazı insanlar
kendilerine verilen de bir türlü
getirmiyorlar kafayı zorluyorlar başka
başka kişilerle başka başka ortamlarla
başka başka deneyimlerle tanışıyor bu
hayatı olabildiğince farklı düzeylerde
en gözlemlemeye ve denemeye çalışıyor ve
bu insanlar Eninde sonunda ilginç bir
şeylerle ortaya çıkıyorlar Mesela işte
bildiğiniz ünlü sanatçı var bilim
insanları Demir ise düşünürler falan
filan Bunların hepsi bunu tuhaf insanlar
Aslında bakarsanız kendilerine
öğretilmiş olan da getirmedikleri için
başka bir şey arıyorlar ve başka bir şey
aradıklarında ortaya müthiş bir soru
çıkıyor çoğu zaman Peki bu sadece
sanatçılara düşünürlere ya da işte
doğuştan böyle çok zeki olan insanlara
mahsus hayır öyle değil hepimiz
annelerimizden bir şekilde Aslında böyle
bir video ile doğruyoruz ama çoğumuz
yolda işte Hem kültürümüzün öğrettiği
şeylerden hem de biraz eğitimin
etkisiyle ya bana mı kaldı bu işleri
yapmak Ama ben Kim bunları yapmak lazım
ya bu adam bu kadın Zaten dahilmiş ben
dahi falan dedim ben Normal bir insanın
falan filan diye hiç o işlerin peşinde
ki düşmemeyi öğreniyoruz Martı Vine çok
güzel bir sözü vardır Amerikalı yazar
Ben çok severim bir grup çocuk bir şey
başarıyorlar hikâyesinde ve McQueen
onlar için diyor ki o işin imkansız
olduğunu bilmedikleri için başardılar
diyor bize şimdi hayatımızda birçok şey
Mümkün değil imkansız sen yapamazsın biz
yapamayız buradan kimse yapamaz gibi
kodlarla öğretiliyor Halbuki bunlar bize
bu şekilde öğretilmesi Biz belki de çok
inanılmaz şeyler yapabilir olacağız bir
Tabii ki bu da Etraftaki insanların suçu
değil onlar da bildiklerini ailelerinden
etrafından gördüklerini bizi
aktarıyorlar bu da işte benim burada
özellikle genç arkadaşları anlatmak
istediğim çok özel bir konu var o da şu
ki hayatı yavaş yavaş denemeye
deneyimlemeye ve Farklı farklı
insanlarla tanışmaya başladığımızda
kendi gelişimimize dair Nasıl bir insan
olacağımıza dair gözümüzün kulağımızın
çok açık olması lazım Biz genellikle bu
adına o ben dediğimiz şeyin Artık bize
ait olmadığını fark etmiş olmalı canım
Ben dediğim şey tuttuğun takım ismim de
dahil olmak üzere başkalarının
tercihlerinden oluşuyor Peki gerçek bir
beni Acaba nasıl ortaya çıkarabilirim
mesela şu anda bir işte futbol takımını
taraftar olarak kendi yakın hissediyor
olabilirsiniz bunun ömür boyunca
gitmesinde hiçbir sıkıntı yok ya da bir
yemeği hiç yemenize rağmen
sevmediğinizi düşünüyor olabilirsiniz
şurada bir tuhaflık var hiç yemediğiniz
bir yemeği neden sever yada sevmezsiniz
genelde sevmezsiniz de sevme durumu pek
fazla olmaz genellikle ben onu hayatta
yemem diye bir şey söyler insanlar
bakalım Muhtemelen yakın çevremizde anne
baba da yakala birisi o yemekten kötü
bahsetmiştir Yoo size bir kötü bir imaj
olarak kalmıştır Siz hiç o yemeği
tatmaya veya beğenmezsiniz ama ben bunun
canlı örneğini gördüm 40 Ben yarın da
babam bir gün bir yemekte Hayatında ilk
defa bakla yemeğinin tadına baktı hem de
ona iyi gönderdiği zaman annem dedi ki
ben baklava hiç sevmem Annem dedi ki bir
kereye Sen ne olur Babam bir tadına
baktı Ondan sonra hala otursaydı sürekli
bakla Yar çok seviyor baklayı Çünkü bize
uygun Sofrası dediği şey benim için çok
öğretici dedi Dedi ki bakla çok güzelmiş
de deyince ben dedim Sen niye
sevmiyorsun baklayı Ben ne bileyim annem
sevmezdi Bende hemen bakla dedi Mesela
şimdi bu Tabii bir yemek konusunda çok
fazla zararlı olmayabilir ama
hayatımızda birçok konuda bildiğimiz ya
da bilmediğimiz Blues insan sınırlarımız
var birçoğumuz kendimize şöyle içerden
bakalım öyle bir takım Hayaller
kuruyoruz Aklımızdan bir şeyler geçiyor
belki zengin olma hayali belki ünlü olma
hayali Belki de BİM keşifler icatlar
yapma hayalleri böyle bir şeyler geçiyor
olabilir içinizden ama bazen kendinizi
şöyle yakalıyor olabilirsiniz aman çok
saçma sapan şeyler düşündüm bunlar bana
mı kaldı eğer öyle bir şey geldi saklı
onu hemen kovalayın Çünkü
insanın çok önemli bir süper gücü vardır
bu süper güç Hakkatten o Superman'in
Örümcek Adam'ın Bilmem Kimi süper
gücünden katbekat üstün bir süper güç
tür arada bir Muhakkak bir süper
kahraman olma hayali kurmuşsunuz da
mısın Örümcek Adam olmayı çok isterdim
Ama onların çok ötesinde bir süper güç
Aslında hepimizde var ve Fakat bunun
önemini ve varlığını çoğu zaman
unutabiliriz o gücünü alır şu olmayan
bir geleceği hayal edip onu yaratabilmek
başka hiçbir canlı onu yapamıyorum Sen
bir tane fare oturup düşünüp düşünüp
düşünüp Ben fen bir tane büyük bir kule
inşa edeceğim diyemiyorum sen farklı
böyle bir özellik yok ama
şu anda kullandığınız bilgisayarlar
oturduğunuz koltuk içinde yaşadığınız ev
ya da ofis neresi ise Eğer Bulunduğunuz
mekan
Normalde yoktu birileri onun hayalini
kurdu
sonra onu planladılar adım adım inşa
ettiler ve şu anda fiziksel bir
gerçeklik olarak karşımızda ya da siz
onun içinde buluyoruz bu çok acayip bir
şey insan Dolayısıyla olmayan var
edebilen bir bunun için ne yapmak lazım
hayal gücü denen şeyi asla terk etmek
lazım Hayal kurmak genellikle böyle bize
boş geçmiş gibi söyleniyor ama bazı yeni
hayallere falan diye Halbuki o hülyalar
da gezinmek başka bir şey hayal kurmak
başka bir şey hayal kurmanın da size bir
tarifini önereyim Bu benim tarifim
hayale henüz var olmayan ama bar etme
yolunda yürüdüğünüz
görüntünün imajın o tayin adıdır Siz
eğer oraya doğru o uzanır O sizin
hayalinizde bir öbür türlü Rüya
görüyordur insan ama hayaliniz varsa siz
o hayale doğru hızlı ya da yavaş küçük
adımlar rahat Beyazıt dönemi şekilde
yürüyor olmanız gerekir birçok insan
diyor ki ya ben hayalimi nasıl
yaşayacağım işte diyorum ki onların Ne
hayal ediyorsun biraz konuşuyoruz hiçbir
hayalleri olmadığını anlıyorum ilginç
bir şekilde ve hayalinde dönüyorum 30
sıra sonra ne yapacaksın Ben diyorsa
Doktor olacak ya Bir Hayal değil ki
bugün meslek adı meslek adından Hayal
olmaz Ama şöyle bir şey diyebilirsiniz
Ben öyle bir doktor olacağım ki dünyada
parası olmayan herkese sağlık hizmeti
ulaştıracağım Evet bu gerçekten bir
hayal bu Belki de gerçekten sadece sizin
yapabileceğiniz birşey Eğer bunu siz
Hayal ediyorsanız ve yapmıyorsanız İşte
o zaman belki de bu dünyada bu işi
yapmakla çok ciddi bir sorumluluk da
alıyor olması çok ciddi bir eksiklik
ortaya koyuyor olabilirsiniz ve bunun
sebebide şu biliyorsunuz Hepimiz parmak
izimiz gibi benzersiz bizden başka bir
tane daha yok hepimiz bu dünyaya bir
başkasının Muhtemelen asla yapamayacağı
bir şeyi çok iyi yapmak için geldik ama
onun ne olduğunu Muhtemelen henüz
bilmiyoruz Ben de yaşam hediye yakışır
Ben de hala arıyorum
yani yavaş yavaş Deneye deneye E biraz
okulda ilerlemeye çalışıyorum ama bütün
Ömür özellikle hoşunuza giden devamlı
hayallerimizin meşgul eden yapmanız için
sizi için için ikna etmeye çalışan
sevdiğiniz hayal ettiğiniz şeylerin bir
kombinasyonu bir bileşkesi ile size
müthiş bir yetenek seti rüyasında
doğuştan böyle birşey sahipseniz
yetiştiniz ortamında bunda etkisi var
konuştuğunuz dilinde coğrafyanın da
aldığınız kültüründe her şeyin etkisi
var bir Neticede Siz benzersiz bir insan
ben bir insanın Peki ne yapacağım
hayalimde canlandırdığım devamlı yapmak
istediğim şey yapmanın bir yolunu
bulacağım onu kendimce Yapacağım az
yapacağım çok yapacağım ama bir şekilde
yapacağım ve bu dünyada kendini mutlu
hisseder insanlara bakıyorsunuz ve
bunların arasında bayağı yoksul zorluk
çeken gelmişti Hatta hasta yaralı
bilmediği bir sürü insan var çok
mutluyuz ifade ediyorlar bu insanların
hepsinin ortak özelliği kendi
hayallerinin peşinde görüyorum kendi
hayalin peşinde ilerlediğinizde
ortamlarda şartlardan şikayet etmeyi bir
kenara bırakır o hayale varmanın
heyecanlı yaşarsınız yaşıyorum ben
sınırlardan açma ile uğraşan birisi
olarak bu konuyla ilgili herkese gaz
vermeye çalışıyorum Bugün de eğer Mümkün
olursa sıcak az vermeye geldim İnşallah
söylediklerin mantıklı geliyor Dur ben
kısaca sözlerim teşekkür ederim
ben anlatamadım